moving to Washington President Trump is
making some potentially dangerous new
suggestions for fighting the coronavirus
at his latest briefing he talked about
possibly injecting disinfectant into
people's bodies though he later
partially walked that back
the president also floated the idea of
getting bright light like UV rays into
the body after hearing it's bad for the
virus now this is not the first time
he's pushed treatments without his
Medical Teams endorsement
wooja Jang is at the White House for us
we should good morning at one point the
president said he's up there just trying
to present ideas but these ideas do not
have the endorsement of medical experts
so where do they come from a good
morning Tony president Trump indicated
this came from his own head and he said
it would be a good idea to look at a
possible treatment but as you mentioned
stressed he was just throwing it out
there as a suggestion now the president
made these remarks after an official
with the DHS Office of Science and
Technology presented emerging results
from a study that showed sunlight heat
and humidity along with disinfectants
degraded the virus on surfaces and in
the air I'm just here to present talent
I'm here to present ideas President
Trump called on Bill Bryan a Department
of Homeland Security official to outline
early results from a study that showed
the effect of heat on the virus our most
striking observation to date is the
powerful effect that solar light appears
to have on killing the virus both
surfaces and in the air we've seen a
similar effect with both temperature and
humidity as well but Brian also said
Americans should still follow CDC
guidance on social distancing and
personal health practices we identified
that heat and humidity is a weakness in
that chain we've identified that
sunlight solar light UV rays as a
weakness in that chain that doesn't take
away the other activities the guidance
from the White House the guidance from
the CDC and others on the actions and
steps that people need to take to
protect themselves CBS News medical
contributor dr. David agus said the
study shows promise but isn't a cure-all
we still have to practice social
distancing we still have to wear
masks but you tie together mass social
distancing and the changes that happen
in the summer out of doors and I think
we will be on offense against this virus
and my hope is we're gonna get
significantly decreased cases over the
summer having heard the findings the
president had suggestions for treatments
for patients supposing we hid the body
Mendes
whether it's ultraviolet or just very
powerful light and then I see the
disinfectant where it knocks it out in a
minute
one minute and is there a way we can do
something like that by injection inside
or almost a cleaning I would like you to
speak to the medical doctors to see if
there's any way that you can apply light
and heat to cure Debra have you ever
heard of that the heat and the light
relative to certain viruses yes but
relative to this virus that is a
treatment after all this unfolded
medical experts swiftly and strongly
started urging people not to improperly
use disinfectants and the manufacturer
of Lysol says in a statement under no
circumstance should our disinfectant
products be administered into the human
body
Gail very good advice and we have to say
it's so important to follow the advice
of doctors and medical experts I think
we shall out of people felt for dr.
Burks as she looked like she was trying
to hold her face on straight there
yesterday again please please please
follow the advice of doctors and medical
experts we should we thank you